this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash bio to get a
two-year plan at a huge discount plus a
free gift more on them in a bit
my name is ozymandias king of kings look
on my works you mighty
and despair english romantic poet percy
bishelly wrote those famous words in
1818 to show that even the greatest of
men and their mighty empires still fall
prey to the ravages of time destined to
fade into oblivion the name he chose was
ozymandias which was what the ancient
greeks called the egyptian pharaoh
ramesses ii baramusi's legacy was still
alive in shelley's time and if anything
it's going even stronger today all you
have to do is take a walk through malden
luxor or abbas bell to be reminded that
the pharaoh and his work still fascinate
us
3200 years later ramesses is almost
unheard of 66-year reign as pharaoh gave
ancient egypt its final glory days one
last golden age before it all started
going downhill and the civilization
never managed to regain its full
strengths ever again it is clear to see
why later egyptians started referring to
ramesses ii as the great ancestor
[Music]
ramesses ii was born circa 1303 bc into
the 19th dynasty of ancient egypt
arguably the most powerful dynasty of
the new kingdom period this lineage was
founded by ramesses the first our
protagonist's grandfather who had served
as vizier to the last fair of the
previous dynasty he only reigns for a
couple of years but he set the scene for
egypt to enter a new golden age once his
son seti the first took the throne said
he had a good reign of 10-15 years and
brought some much-needed stability to
his kingdom which was still in political
and religious turmoil following the
monotheistic revolution attempted by
akhenaten which had only happened around
40 years earlier but of course if you
want to learn about that old kettle of
fish check out our video on akenaton the
pharaoh branded a heretic anyway seti
the first proved to be a strong leader
at a crucial point for egypt as the
nation was not only facing internal
struggles but also external ones mainly
in the form of its arch enemy the
hittite empire the hittites had started
out of the city of hatusa which is
located in the middle of modern-day
turkey but had successfully expanded
south into syria until they reached the
borders of egypt as pharaoh said he took
a woman named tuya as his great royal
wife and they had several children
together seti named his eldest son after
his own father ramesses ii now i'm not
going to go into ramesses the second own
family tree for two simple reasons one
there were just too many people he had
countless wives and concubines and
fathered around a hundred children and
two a lot of them died before ramesses
anyway so they never really got the
chance to do anything noteworthy in fact
the king who ultimately succeeded
ramesses on the throne was mernair patar
his 13th son who was already in his 60s
by the time he became pharaoh this
really puts into context just how long
ramesses reign truly was it has been
suggested although never definitively
proven that seti made ramesses
co-regions in his last years as pharaoh
seti died circa 1279 bc thus paving the
way for rameses ii to become the third
king of the 19th dynasty
[Applause]
ramesses was in his early 20s when he
assumed power although he had received
training and been awarded all sorts of
fancy titles and positions since he was
a child he was still a greenhorn when it
came to actual military matters even so
he showed himself to be quite eager to
go on the warpath and actually guard his
most famous tribe just a few years into
his seven decade reign when he fought
the hittites at the battle of gadesh now
the city of qadesh was very important to
ramesses both from a strategic and a
personal perspective it was a valuable
military asset because it was a
fortified city and a major trading
center located between the borders of
the egyptian and hittite empires at a
time when the two powers often butted
heads with one another remember this was
3 300 years ago and moving an entire
army through the syrian desert was a
tricky proposition having a city like
kadesh on your side to serve as your
base of operations could mean the
difference between victory and a fee
which is why both egypt and hatusa
wanted to control it then on a personal
level capturing kadesh and seti's
greatest achievement he was unable to
keep it though and qadesh fell under
hittite dominion again soon after the
pharaoh left so ramesses may have wanted
to finish what his father had started
therefore he immediately set to work
building a grand army to drive the
hittites from syria once and for all in
1274 bc only five years into his reign
the forces were ready and the omens were
auspicious so the egyptian army marched
on kadesh battle of kadesh is also
special because thanks to detailed
inscriptions from both sides it might be
the most well-documented military
conflict in all of ancient history
ramesses had twenty thousand soldiers on
his side split into four divisions ammun
rare set and pta we don't have exact
figures for the hittites who were led by
king moatly ii but they were joined by
19 different vassals so presumably they
weren't hurting for soldiers one notable
thing about this battle was the large
number of chariots that were used each
side deployed around 2500 making this
possibly the largest chariot battle in
history despite what the egyptian
inscriptions might say the battle of
qadesh was not a resounding victory for
egypt and ramesses did not show himself
to be some kind of napoleon level
strategist quite the opposite in fact as
we said the pharaoh was still a young
man and his pride and naivety almost
cost him not only the battle but also
his life ramesses had received reports
from a couple of passing nomads that the
enemy in pure astonishment of his mighty
awesomeness had begun retreating to
aleppo a more sensible person might be
somewhat skeptical of such information
but not ramesses he saw it as the
perfect opportunity to capture kadesh
now that the bulk of its defence force
had left therefore he assembled his
division of soldiers and began marching
immediately leaving the other three
divisions to catch up you can probably
guess what happened next the hittites
were not in aleppo they were in kadesh
waiting patiently and the pharaoh just
got suckered into their trap eventually
ramesses realized that he was walking
right into an ambush but by then it was
too late the hittites were getting ready
to charge his cab so the only thing he
could do was send word for the other
divisions to hurry up and to hope that
he could hold out until then of course
we don't know how much of what happened
next is fact and how much is propaganda
but ramesses apparently acted as a
fierce and mighty warrior once the
fighting started rallying his scattered
soldiers several times and personally
leading his guard to repeatedly punch
holes into the enemy ranks the pharaoh
managed to hold the opposing forces at
bay until reinforcements arrived at
which point the tide turned and the
hittite army became overwhelmed they
tried retreating but were caught between
egyptian forces and the orontes river
where they were either slaughtered or
drowned curiously king mortality still
had a large army within kadesh but he
chose not to deploy it instead
fortifying the city despite standing
victorious once the fighting was over
ramesses still found himself outside the
city walls looking in he did not have
the forces or supplies necessary to wage
a long siege so he had no choice but to
scurry on back to egypt as to who won
the battle of kadesh that really depends
on who you ask the egyptians
unsurprisingly hailed it as a glorious
victory and celebrated it on temple
walls stalin and pylons all over the
kingdom the airtights thought they won
since ultimately they stopped the enemy
from achieving their main goal of
capturing kadesh realistically we should
call this battle inconclusive but it's
true ramifications would not become
obvious for another decade and a half
alright we'll get back to today's video
in just a moment but first a quick word
from today's video sponsor nordvpn
here's something you may already know
everyone uses the internet a little bit
differently and that's fine but what you
don't want to do is leave yourself
unprotected online you may have heard me
talk about what nordvpn can do for you
previously it encrypts your internet
data and moves your online activity to
another location with just one click
either for superior security or just
more streaming options and all of that
is still true nordvpn has more than 5
000 servers throughout 60 countries but
vpns give you access to so much more
than just new tv shows you having
trouble connecting to social media no
problem nordvpn you want to buy a video
game that's cheaper somewhere else or
maybe just not even available in your
country nordvpn wants to route your
internet connection through multiple
servers just for double layered
protection yeah nordvpn too with nordvpn
you can do it all and that includes
utilizing their threat protection
upgrade which blocks ads eradicates web
trackers and checks for malware and so
much more right now as part of a special
deal you guys can get a two-year plan at
a huge discount plus an additional bonus
gift on top of that and if you try nord
and change your mind they offer a 30-day
money-back guarantee all you got to do
is head to nordvpn.com forward slash bio
again nordvpn dot com forward slash bio
for a two year deal at a huge discount
plus a bonus gift on top of that or just
follow the link in the description box
below and now back to today's video
ramesses feud with the hittites was far
from over but they weren't his only
enemies the perro had lost the ambitions
of bringing about a new golden age for
egypt which included conquering lands
that had not been a part of his kingdom
for decades even centuries such as
canaan at the same time he had to
protect his own territory from invaders
such as the sea peoples now in case
you've never heard of the sea peoples
they are probably one of the most
mysterious civilizations of the ancient
world we do not have any first hand
information on them they left nothing
behind to be studied but we do know of
them through the prison of their enemies
and they had a lot of enemies the sea
peoples were a confederation of multiple
seafaring groups who banded together
sometime during the 13th century bc and
started wreaking havoc on all the
civilizations in the mediterranean by
raiding their coastal towns and cities
the egyptians the hittites the greeks
and the phoenicians all had to contend
with the sea peoples today we don't
really know where they came from or what
ultimately happened to them but the
invasions of the sea peoples are
considered an important contributor to
the late bronze age collapse a dark
period for many of the mediterranean
cultures as far as egypt was concerned
it was ramesses successors who mainly
had to fight them off but they proved to
be a minor headache during his time as
well the qadesh inscriptions which were
made to celebrate ramesses victory at
the battle of kadesh casually mentioned
that he had to fight off an attack from
raiding sea pirates called the sherdon
in his second year as pharaoh ramesses
defeated the raiders by luring them into
the nile delta and then pressed the
prisoners into service using them as
mercenaries against the hittites
speaking of whom it was about time for
that conflict to heat up again a couple
of years had passed since the battle of
kadesh enough time for both sides to
regain their strength and get ready for
round two this happened around ramesses
seventh year as pharaoh he took the
egyptian army into syria again but faced
a similar scenario one that his father
had also encountered even if he did
conquer new lands he simply could not
keep them as soon as he left those
kingdoms either went independent again
or fell under the hegemony of the
hittites who fanned the flames of
rebellion from afar and encouraged any
kind of uprising against egypt ramesses
led yet another military campaign into
syria in his eighth regular year but
even though he made it further up north
than ever before reaching a lost city
called depor it was still just rinse and
repeat when the pharaoh went to play the
hittites came to play as we said
ramesses had ambitious goals he wanted
to achieve he couldn't spend his entire
reign trading border cities with hatusa
especially when it became quite clear
that neither empire was strong enough to
gain a decisive upper hand over the
other therefore once that third syrian
campaign had ended the feud between
egypt and tatusa took a time out with
the two powerhouses living side by side
in a labored peace their tense
relationship culminated in 1258 bc a
landmark moment in history when ramesses
ii and hattu saleed the third king of
the hittite empire signed the treaty of
kadesh the world's earliest known peace
treaty it happened during the 21st
regular year of ramesses 16 years after
the battle of qadesh the treaty was
written on silver tablets in two
languages egyptian hieroglyphics and
acadian cuneiform and one copy was given
to each civilization the silver
originals are long gone but copies were
made on clay tablets and some of them
still survived to this day with one
replica even adorning the walls of the
united nations building in new york city
tablets are nicer all but egyptians like
to go big and so they carved their
version of the treaty into the temple
walls a karnak perhaps the most
surprising aspect was that the peace
actually lasted the cynics amongst you
must have suspected that this was nearly
a stalling tactic as each side waited
for the perfect opportunity to pounce on
the other when it was weak but that
didn't happen the hittites had a new
threat to contend within the form of the
assyrians so they were glad to get egypt
off their backs the piece lasted for
around 80 years until the collapse of
the hittite empire under invasions by
assyria and the sea peoples meanwhile
once ramesses realized the futility of
trying to control lands up in syria he
focused his attention somewhere else the
pharaoh's efforts up north might have
proved to be in vain but there was still
nubia to the south and libya to the west
in the past parts of both regions had
fallen under egyptian hegemony and
ramesses was all about resurrecting the
glory days of egypt therefore both made
obvious targets we know that ramesses
led military campaigns into each region
but not much more than that other than
the fact that the pharaoh was successful
in expanding his kingdom's borders it
was quite a long way from the battle of
kadesh where we knew the names and
movements of each division there are two
likely explanations for this one most of
the records were destroyed or two the
pharaoh did not achieve anything that
was worthy to write on the temple walls
it seems that ramesses got most of the
fighting out of his system in the first
half of his reign of course he didn't
know ahead of time that he would be
pharaoh for almost 70 years so in the
immortal words of danny glover maybe he
was just getting too old for this [ __ ]
either way ramesses lasting legacy came
not as a conqueror but as a builder
[Music]
to put it simply ramesses the great was
one of ancient egypt's most prolific
builders if not the most prolific and
we're counting the old kingdom pharaohs
who were obsessed with pyramids the
thing with ramesses was that he built
and repaired a lot of small-scale stuff
roads storehouses docks temples etc that
were useful but unlikely to feature on
any seven wonders list that being said
the pharaoh also had grand ambitions and
he showed them from the beginning of his
reign by building an entire city to
serve as his new capital pyramids by all
accounts the city already existed in
ramesses time most likely founded by his
father or grandfather veroceti the first
even built a palace there to use as a
little summer getaway since pyramics was
located near the mouth of the nile river
on its easternmost branch whereas the
egyptian capital of thebes was over 700
kilometers south of the nile delta but
ramesses decided to take this small
settlement and transform it into a
metropolis of great splendor whose
magnificence rivaled and even surpassed
that of the old capital he started by
building four giant temples each
dedicated to a different deity amun said
warjet and most curious of all astate a
canaanite goddess adopted by the
egyptians as their own then he added
residential areas docks storehouses
treasuries canals markets military
barracks training facilities and farms
everything needed to turn pyramids into
a thriving cultural religious and
economic center one question that still
puzzles archaeologists is what exactly
made ramesses choose that particular
spot was it personal practical or
propaganda or maybe all three it could
have been personal because young
ramesses grew up in that area so maybe
he simply had a soft spot for the nile
delta it could have been practical from
a military standpoint the pharaoh knew
that the hittites were going to be a
major thorn in his side so he needed a
capital that was closer to the action
whereas thebes was much further down
south and it could have also been a bit
of clever propaganda on behalf of
ramesses who wanted the position himself
as the leader of a new golden age for
egypt his new capital was located very
close to the city of avariz which had
served as the capital during the hix
period the hickos had been the first
foreigners to conquer egypt's ruling as
the 15th dynasty for a hundred years
they were eventually defeated by omose
the first who became the founder of the
new kingdom period since then avarice
had become a symbol of triumph over
adversity for the egyptians so it would
not be too surprising that ramesses
wanted to associate himself with that
unfortunately we can only speculate as
to how grand and opulent pyramics looked
at the peak of its power it seems that
the dynasties that followed were not too
fond of the city and began ignoring it
then the 21st dynasty moved the capital
once more this time to tennis and
pyramids was doomed to serve mainly as
quarry plundered for all of its stone
and other building materials which were
recycled and reused somewhere else the
city was almost completely wiped off the
map to the point that egyptologists
excavated for almost 100 years until
they found the location where it once
stood near the modern village of cantir
the good news is that not all of
ramesses building projects offered the
same fate many of them still stand in
fact at least partially and represent
some of the main attractions for
visitors in egypt looking to travel back
in time to the age of pharaohs first
there is the temple complex at abu
symbol originally carved straight into a
solid grot cliff before it was entirely
relocated during the 1960s like many
other monuments built during ramesses
time this one celebrated his victory at
the battle of kadesh which does make it
seem like the pharaoh rested on his
laurels just a little bit abu simbel
does show us that of all the hundreds of
wives and concubines the ramesses had
his favorite was nefertari his first
great royal wife since she was the only
one who had her own temple albeit much
smaller in scale next to that of the
pharaoh nepatiti does deserve credit
helping to bring peace between egypt and
tusa even though her husband liked to
brag about his victory at kadesh on
every stone he found we know that the
battle was not as conclusive as he
pretended it to be and in the long run
he did little to stop the hittite threat
it was the treaty that stopped the
fighting and nefertari was instrumental
in securing it because she was pen pals
with the hitai queen put a haper clay
tablets recovered from hadusa revealed
correspondence between the two queens
who referred to each other as sister and
talked about marriage alliances between
their two families to bring about peace
between their gods and their husbands
around 12 49 bc ramesses celebrated his
first said festival a very important and
ancient tradition that dated all the way
back to the first dynasty it was a
jubilee that was meant to honor the
pharaoh's long continued rule as well as
renew his strength and keep him going
the first said festival was celebrated
once a pharaoh reigned for 30 years and
subsequent festivals were held every
three years ish so you can imagine that
even just one said festival was a big
deal but ramesses celebrated 14 of them
when he finally died circa 1213 bc he
would have been around 90 years old his
66 year long reign left egypt as a
regional powerhouse both from a military
and economic point of view external
dangers such as the sea peoples
threatened that hegemony but ultimately
it was internal strife and power
struggles that brought about the end of
ancient egypt's third and final golden
age known as the new kingdom as far as
ramesses was concerned he wanted to go
out in style pyramids might no longer
have been in fashion but mortary temples
were the hot new thing during the new
kingdom these buildings were constructed
next to the royal tombs and were used to
prepare the body of the pharaoh for the
afterlife as well as serve as cults of
worship for them long after they were
gone ramesses mortuary temple or the
ramoseem as egyptologists have dubbed it
was not only one of the pharaoh's
grandest building projects but one of
the greatest mortuary temples in egypt
possibly outclassed even by that of
hatchet the latter has the advantage of
still standing whereas ramesses temple
is mostly in ruins prompting percy
shelley to write the words that opened
today's video but ramesses story did not
quite end there because his mummy was
recovered and is today resting
peacefully inside the cairo museum
scientific analysis revealed that the
pharaoh suffered for decades from very
bad arthritis as well as teeth problems
and bad circulation but realistically
for an honorarian from 3000 years ago
that's still pretty damn good we end our
story with a final fun fact about
ramesses the great in 1974 he was flown
to france for some vital preservation
work according to french law however all
people flying into the country alive or
dead needed a valid passport therefore
ramesses became the first and only
pharaoh to be issued a passport by the
egyptian government date of birth 1303
bc occupation king deceased
[Music]
you